[音楽]
dj
うどん
みなさんこんにちは
はじめに
皆さん遊んでいますでしょうか
突然制しました
この質問に対する思い浮かべる答え
こちらだと思います
はぁ
って感じですよね
今はその程度で大丈夫です
このトークを聞いた後で全く印象が変わっ
てくると思います
申し遅れました私阿部隼人と申します
こちらの写真
私の職場です
子どもの頃私は近くの公園でサッカーや
バスケ野球や鬼ごっこなどたくさん様々な
遊びをしてきました
時には母親に
ご飯だから帰ってください
言われたのが懐かしいくらいです
昔も今もスポーツにかかわっていることが
好きな私は今では運動スポーツを通して
子供を育てるいわゆる育成といった仕事を
しています
この仕事をしていく中で
今現代の子供たちの生活について
子供の1日の生活を話してみます
皆さん
目を閉じてイメージしてみてください
子供は朝7時に起きて朝食を食べます
朝食を食べた後学校に行くと思いきや学校
には行かず家の机の前でオンラインで授業
を受けます
オンラインゲー授業を受けた後家でお
昼ご飯を食べて
またオンライン授業を受ける
2時ぐらいでしょうか
オンラインゲー事業を終わった後
このもは公園に遊びたいと思って家の外に
入ってます
しかし公園には遊具にバリケードが貼られ
ておりまた遊んではいけないという看板が
あります
公園で遊べないと気づいた子どもは家に
戻って youtube やゲームをして
一人で遊んでいます
塾の時間になりました
外を入れて宿に向かいます
でも本当は塾に行きたいっていう気持ちは
あまりなくお母さんに塾に行ってきなさい
と言われたので仕方がなく入ってます
でも本当は宿で友達に会うのが楽しいです
勉強が終わったあと家に帰ってお父さんと
お母さんと一緒にごはんを食べます
ご飯を食べた後
お父さんとお母さんと一緒に遊びたいなと
思う気持ちがありますが忙しくて疲れて
なかなか遊べる時間はありません
結局のところ一人でゲームや
youtube をしてそれが1日終わり
明日もあさっても同じような生活をして
いるんです
ありがとうございました目を開けて
ください
ここで私は非常に重要な問題に気づきまし
た
それは子ども遊べてない問題です
子供の遊びは子どもの心身を育てる上で
非常に重要な役割を担っていると考えてい
ます
その中で今の子供の現状をお見せします
これは文科省から発表されている体力
テストの結果です皆さんも小学生の時に
行った事があるはずです
体力テストの合計点は実は昭和60年から
低下傾向となっており今年は遠くに減少し
ていますそれからこの体力テストでは
子どもの肥満についても報告されています
見てわかるとおり今年は数値がさらに向上
ししてしまっています
実は子どもの肥満低大人につながって
しまいます
っつ一刻も早く手を打たないと手遅れに
なってしまいますし
これはヤバいんじゃないかと非常に不安に
なっています
ということで私はこの課題を解決しようと
研究しました
その中で子供が遊ぶために必要なこと3つ
に気づきました
それが3つのまです
さてみなさんこれ
なんだと思いますか
見てる方
もしよかったらコメントの方にちょっとよ
そう書いてみてください
どしどしお願いします
さあこの3つのま
必要なものです何でしょうか
例えば
3つのま一つ目
今日はこれを紹介したいと思いますまあ
なんと今日世界が滅びるらしい
まあ
知らせ
間違えましたこれは違いますそれとも次は
まあ
ですね今日はこれについてはい
説明するわけがありません
すいません間違えました続いていき
ましょう
ま
そうですこれは僕が大好きな魔人ブウ
今日は魔人ブウについて話そうと思います
すいませんこれも違います
発音記号です
筑波大生が頭が良すぎてこれを選んで
しまったそうです
違います
正解そろそろ言いましょう
正解は3つのま
です
さてこれは何のことでしょうか
3つの場というのは
空間時間仲間を意味します
これらを説明しますと一つ目は空間
このように公園にはバリケードやシールが
振られてしまっておりなかなか遊べない
空間がありかつ
看板があり例えばサッカー野球など遊びが
金されている看板があります
続いて
仲間失礼しました次いで時間です
子供は多くの習い事を実施していることが
多く1週間に複数の習い事をしていると
いうデータもあります
次に仲間です
この写真のようにひとりでゲームをしてい
たり遊ぶ時間がありませんか
児童の正体割合でいうと一人っ子が多い
そうです
続いてこの写真の通り
この3つの間時間空間仲間が揃うとなぜか
子供って勝手に遊びだします
これが揃ったらむしろ大人の海には入ら
ない入ってはいけないかもしれません
それでは遊び出すと何が起きているの
でしょうか
皆さんも一緒に考えてみてください
例えばこれ単純な鬼ごっこです
皆さんもやったことがあると思いますが
じつはこのとき
鬼や場所時間などさまざまなルールを決め
ています
そのルール設定にも柔軟性が求められ
例えば1年生と3年生が同じ空間にいると
したら同じルールで戦うためにそのルール
を設定しないといけません
また
この線からこの戦までしか走ってはいけ
ないとかそういうふうに環境を作ることが
求められます
その中では話すことが必要になるので提案
や議論これを繰り返します
環境が整えば子どもは本能的に狂ったよう
に走り回るのです
子供の遊びの中で何が起きているのか
なんとなくでも皆さんご理解いただけた
でしょうか
今日私は
子どもに関わる全ての
方々にこの3つのま
を用意してほしい
子供を塾や習い事に押し込んで実は遊ぶ
時間がない
そんな状況になっていませんか
思いっきりん
外で遊べる公園はありますか
家の中で遊んだとしても子供の良き仲間
相手として一緒に
遊んであげたりしてますか
ちなみに私は子供の時
雨でも遊びたくて archi 大雨が
降ってるなぁと思ってもボールが切りたく
て
家の中でサッカーをしました
家の症状細い張ったという新記録を持って
います
みなさんこれは笑うところです
実はこれ
大学生たちも無関係ではありません
子どもを育てるというのや親や大人だけで
はなくて地域や社会全体で子どもを育てて
いきます
私は自立というのは子供この3つのま
を自分の力で用意できることだと思ってい
ます
大学生の皆さん
自分で計画して時間や空間仲間を作って
遊ぶ
こうやって自立しているということだと
思いませんか
今のうちにこの3つのまを用意していると
将来親になったときに子供をたくさん遊ば
せることができるはずです
では
子供に3つ生を用意している重要性が皆様
ご理解いただけたと思います
ここでまた次の疑問が頭をよぎってしまい
ます
最近私はこの課題が子どもの問題げっだけ
じゃないということに改めて気づきました
子供ってやはり大人の背中を見て育ちます
よね
その大人って
遊んでいるのかなということで一気に今
までの複製を回収していきましょう
私が最近発見した課題
それは大人遊べてない問題です
子供の暇を例にあげましたが大人の暇は
なぜいけないのか
言うまでもありませんね
みなさんが見て聞くやばいとするような
こういう病気のリスクに脅かされているの
です
子供の遊びを紹介しましたが
こういう子どもの遊びから大人が薄日と
いうのはこういうイメージをするのでは
ないでしょうか
でもこういう音流すのではなくてむしろ他
の遊びがあると思っています
例えばこの写真
実は私福島県のいわき市小名浜という
ところで育ち海が近いところで生まれ育ち
ました
水をよランニングしたり自転車で走ったり
することが多いです
1人で行くこともありますがもちろん仲間
と一緒に行くこともあります
真っ白の写真は雪と戯れている写真です
スノーボードでジャンプをしたりクルクル
回るというところまでは残念ながら行け
ませんが普段慣れない運動することで自分
の体と向き合ったり逆にそれを仲間に伝え
たりすることが楽しいです
ふと考えたときになぜ私は遊ぶのか冷静に
考えました
私は自分に正直なので自分の本能のままに
何か9分を変えたい
発散したい
話したい
普段とは異なる環境に体を守っていきたい
そんな感情なのです
おそらく皆さんの中でもあるはずです
私の趣味は比較的アクティブなことが多い
ですが皆さんにも他の趣味もはや遊びが
あるはずです
子供が本能的に3つの真の中でたくさん
遊ぶことが重要である通り大人もより人と
触れ合いそしてアクティブに
仲間や人脈を作りそれが創造性とつながり
よりポジティブに未来へ向かって遊びを
作り出す
これこそが重要なことではないでしょうか
このご時世で在宅バークはオンライン授業
が増えていると思います
だからこそ皆さんの本能が求めているので
はないでしょうか
大人も子どもも同じ
遊ぶことは非常に大事なのです
そしてこの3つのまを作り
人と関わっていくことがこれからの新しい
人生を創っていくきっかけになるのでは
ないでしょうか
お子さんがいる方はぜひ一緒にこの3つの
場をつくってたくさん遊んであげて
ください
大学生などこれから親になるかもしれない
方々も今のうちにたくさん仲間達と同じ
空間や時間を作ってさまざまな遊びをして
みましょう
子供って
3つ生いまご荘櫂した空間時間仲間さえ
それをさにすれば勝手に遊びだします
とにかく遊びたくてしょうがない自分たち
で遊びを作っていきます
よく考えると大人ってお金や車を持って
いるので実は簡単に自分の力で3つの刃を
つくれるということができちゃうと思って
ます
最近流行りのマッチングアプリだって18
歳以上しか使えない
これは言う必要がありませんでしたすみ
ません
だからこそ大人が子供に3つ生を用意して
あげるをあげることこそが必要なんです
大人が子供に遊んでる姿を背中を見せる
必要があると確信しています
最後に今回の手で x 筑波のテーマです
テーマの文章を紹介します
子供の頃
世界は驚きと発見にあふれる
遊び場んだったのに大人になるとみんな
忘れてしまう
思い出そう
この世界は遊び場だ
これで終わりにしたいと思います
ありがとうございました
[拍手]